yeah now you can show this sack
uh oregon's natural spaces feel off
limits to black people we are told this
is
uh this is opb's this is oregon public
broadcasting oregon's uh npr station uh
we're being told that parks and
trailheads are slowly reopening as they
as they should be we've got an extended
anecdote from someone a black woman who
uh explains that while she was excited
initially when she moved to
portland area to start going outside
when she did go she found that she was
one of very few black people on the
trails
and um and then the logical leap felt
that that was due to racism and that she
was experiencing racism from all the
non-black people that she saw
there is a quote in this article i don't
know exactly where it is on the page
right now
uh quote recent data from the oregon
parks and recreation department shows
black people are under
underrepresented as visitors to state
parks they make up 2.2 percent of
oregon's population
and 0.9 percent of daily visitors and
1.9 of overnight visitors to parks
so it's a really white state
whole pacific northwest is really really
really white right 2.2 percent of the
population is black that's about 1 in
50.
therefore even if there was exact
representation
due to race on the trails only 1 in 50
people you'd see would be black
you'd still feel like you were rare
because
you are and that may be due to other
issues that might need addressing but
that has nothing to do
with whether or not the trails don't
have enough black people on them
overnight visitors 1.9 versus 2.2 total
that doesn't look far off at all
0.9 of daily visitors we don't know if
that's
actually not representative there are no
statistics here and even if it were
what is it that the claim is that is
keeping
people of color black people off the
trails
well i i read uh as far into this
article as i could get myself to read
um and the person and i you know i don't
want to belittle her perspective
for one thing it may be accurate but
what she says is that it's the
looks that she gets from people on the
trails
the problem is we're now in the
evergreen paradigm which is
okay that claim in and of itself
could mean that you're getting looks
that mean something or it could mean
that you're getting looks but you're
misinterpreting them or it could be that
you're not getting looks and you're
imagining it
we have no way of knowing you would have
to test this somehow
but the thing that's getting me is i
don't know where it is somewhere in one
of our early
live streams i used this exact example
to prove that the fact of a disparity in
representation
does not mean that it's racism right you
will find
blacks underrepresented in recreational
cycling for example
yes is i have worked in a bike shop is
that because bike shops are in some way
reluctant to sell bikes to black people
no bike shops are inhabited by liberals
who probably if anything would feel
extra good
about doing so so it's not the bike
shops i don't think i've never seen any
evidence that a bike lane was racist
i just it's very hard to see
where the bias would be you realize that
you are now introducing hypotheses into
the world
that some people will take and run with
or bike with
something but look let's be honest about
this and let's
steel man the position i actually do
think there's racism
somewhere in these biases right and
which biases the biases that we would
see
racially on trails or bike lanes or
something right
the racism is way way way way upstream
okay it has to do with differential
access
in other words why do you and i end up
on trails right we came from families
who did this where did the families get
this idea well they had
a was in the culture of those families
that you know
neither of them came from privilege but
there was a certain amount of
access there was a certain amount of
expectation and the point is different
people end up valuing different things
now
i think it'd be great if people spent
more time outdoors irrespective of who
they were
right i think we need more outdoor space
in order to make that better right so
that you could actually get away from
people given the
huge population of the planet but the
fact that there may be some differential
access
issue that has kept some populations
farther away from trails does not mean
that there's anything about those modern
day trails
that is in any way less accessible right
so
culture is the clear conspicuous likely
place that some sort of bias would live
not at the trailhead right and it's also
true and this is
also a point that we've made multiple
times before
that when you get looks that don't seem
right and that aren't the
looks that you were hoping for expecting
you can think of yourself and what
demographic markers you have and imagine
that it is due to the ones that are most
likely
to have bias against them in the
population
and sometimes that will be true you know
sometimes i get looks
or comments or yelled at or whatever and
it is because i'm a woman and the dude
yelling is
is a dude and that is what it is and
sometimes it's not
and with regard to sexism you could tell
in part when it is because of the nature
of the comments
and sometimes you can't tell for sure at
all and with race
obviously you could tell in the context
of some comments but
i don't boy you know that's not what's
happening on the trails
like you know and she doesn't say that
they're you know no one is making
explicitly racist comments to this woman
and her son on the trails
but um you know is she getting looks of
surprise shock disappointment
interest pleasure you know any number of
things
that might also be mixed mixed with or
you know
causally related to not i don't think
you belong here but
i didn't expect to see you because
actually you know no one's doing this
math explicitly but 1 in 50 people
are black in oregon and frankly fewer
than that tend to
on the trails yeah and that has nothing
to do
with therefore i don't want you on the
trails so i experienced this a little
bit in a different place and i just want
to talk about
i think how you deal with this
responsibly when you don't know
what you're up against okay when my last
name gets invoked
i often see something flash across the
eyes of somebody that i'm interacting
with right
and it you know i'm betting that some
fraction of the time it's oh
jewish right now sometimes that might be
an anti-semite
very rarely i would imagine right but
the point is there's no
content in just the flicker of somebody
has recognized something that you can
interpret with any sort of certainty
right so
you have to file it agnostically what
was that i don't know
and i assume it's nothing and even if it
was some sort of mild anti-semitism or
suspicion or something that somebody
harbors a what happens next
is the interaction likely overwhelms
whatever prejudice they walked into it
with and you know we know this we know
that what
addresses prejudice successfully is
[Music]
interaction
you